That's right!
I'm going to marry Hinode...
and move out of here as soon as I can!
In order to do so...
I can't let this chance slip away.
I love him,
and not just because he took me in.
He named me, a female cat, "Taro."
That was the name of his previous dog.
He's so loyal.
He's smart,
but he doesn't take it for granted.
Taro!
I know what he's really like.
He ignores me when I'm Muge,
and that makes me sad.
But when I'm Taro, he's so sweet to me.
I love you, Taro.
You always smell like the sun.
Hinode!
I... I'm actually...
What is it?
I can't do it.
I don't have the courage
to tell him I'm Muge.
You're so lucky, Taro.
What's wrong, Hinode?
How can I help you?
I have to make my lunch for tomorrow.
He's making his own lunch box?
I want to eat it...